well it's very interesting to get a call
from the head of HBO saying what can we
do and I went Kim Cattrall is breaking
her silence on her highly anticipated
return to the Sex in the City franchise
as she is confirmed to make a cameo in
season 2 finale of and just like that
how big is his
I'm not allowed to be me so I'm going to
be Samantha the 66 year old actress
stopped by The View on Wednesday to Dish
on her new Netflix series glamorous but
of course the hosts had to ask about
reprising her role as the iconic PR
Powerhouse Samantha Jones
I'm just gonna say the thing you're not
supposed to say I
I love you but I love me more fans
myself included are just thrilled to
hear that you're going to have a scene
in the new season of and just like that
reprisingly
[Applause]
I know you can't tell us much
but what what can you share with us
well it's very interesting to get a call
from the head of HBO saying what can we
do and I went
let me get creative and one of those
things was to get padfield back oh
because I just thought you know if I'm
going to come back I got to come back
with that kind of Samantha style yeah I
gotta push it yeah
and we did I'm so excited so it sounds
like Kim knew exactly what she wanted
from HBO before coming back and that
included the return of designer Patricia
fields to really seal the deal as Sex in
the City fans will know field famously
dressed the cast in the original series
and it's two spin-off movies however
field did not return for season one of
the sequel series due to her commitments
on Emily in Paris but news broke last
month that she would indeed return for
season two alongside her good friend Kim
catrell
according to variety catrell filmed a
cliffhanging cameo on March 22nd in New
York City and was dressed by Fields the
outlet also reports that catrell did her
scene without seeing or speaking with
the stars of the series including Sarah
Jessica Parker Cynthia Nixon and Kristen
Davis
in addition Cattrall reportedly did not
interact with series Creator Michael
Patrick k at this point in my life
especially where I want to spend the
time and with whom is very important to
me yes and what I want to say with the
characters that I play so I've learned
through the years to sort of take a step
back and see myself doing something and
really register how that feels yeah does
that feel right or no I should be over
on this trick over here that feels more
me more now